mein Haushaltsziel
lautet Freunde macht keinen
Führerschein
aus folgendem Grund zum einen natürlich
in der Umwelt
das ist das wichtigste zum zweiten
und fast
genauso wichtig
man wird als Mensch
Führerschein
durchs Leben chauffiert
weil der Satz
ich habe keinen Führerschein
ein südirischen Cen Mitleid
bei den eigenen mit Menschen auslöst
dass man permanent mit genommen wird
weil die Menschen dieser Haltung
entwickeln
man kann den noch nie nachts um drei auf
dem Parkplatz am Walldorfer Kreuz stehen
lassen
dann fahren wir halt den Umweg über
Frankfurt und wurde nach München müsse
deshalb macht keinen Führerschein das
Mitgefühl eure Mitmenschen zeigt sich
im Moment
eures Alleinseins ohne Führerschein
spät nachts
der wahre Freund
hierdurch mitnehmen
der der kein wahrer ist beide stehen
lassen
kann man auch gleich darin ist sich Prof
Ende
ein bisschen